we've had this gentleman on once before
chris it was
uh a no-brainer to have him call in when
we were in philadelphia for the draft
he came in he came in he did not yes he
did yes he did he did that's right he
did we were in like a carl weathers came
in
empty up in this office building i
forgot about that it made me feel like i
was about to get whacked
yeah well at the time um
he was not yet part of one of the best
streaming shows
around um season two of the mandalorian
premieres
uh this very friday on disney plus he
plays the role of grief karga
the man himself carl weather's back on
the rich island show how are you carl
well rich i'm fantastic how are you this
morning and how dare you
forget that i was actually there at the
draft you know what carl come on
no i know you were there i remember it
was great to see you it was great to see
you in philadelphia
it was such a great event to be a part
of and certainly back in
philadelphia where it all began what is
it like for you to walk around the city
of brotherly love
carl weathers what is that how about no
matter where i am
anyone from philadelphia who meets me
who comes up uh they first of all are
just so fantastic happy to see me
but on top of that they just want to
make sure i know that they're from
philly
and that their beloved rocky was from
philly
and did they hold you responsible in any
way shape or form about anything that's
uh that's happened
yeah they hold me responsible for all
the success of the rockies
of course of course they do you know
it's interesting uh
we we had a conversation about that and
before we get to um
you know other aspects of your career as
well as uh
other parts of um what's going on with
with uh disney plus
when you first received that script for
rocky what did you think
carl when you first got out oh man well
i i mean that was a lot of years ago of
course and right
be honest with you i thought it was one
of the best scripts i've
i'd ever read and i'd read a few before
that but
uh it was something that just grabbed me
really by the heart man and i thought
oh my god this is me this character
apollo creed
um this is the one you know and uh
lo and behold through obviously some
struggle and some uh
some effort to convince the producers to
meet me because i was
you know quote unquote a nobody at the
time uh nobody knew me
outside of some roles i'd done on
television uh
and some commercials i've done of course
but uh you know i wasn't a name i wasn't
that
that movie star that they were looking
for at the time and uh
as it turns out uh thank god that uh i
was the right guy in the right place at
the right time
and um i i like to call it carl um
rocky is not a sports movie it's a love
story would you agree with that
i agree with you completely it happens
to be a love story set in the world of
sports
uh um so yes um and a wonderful love
story in fact
uh i think rocky and apollo make a great
couple don't you
uh you know what um carl it's it's a
love story between
uh obviously uh him and adrian rocky and
adrian but then again the blossoming
friendship between you know apollo creed
and and rocky as uh
obviously the series moved along well
you know the thing is it depends on how
you interpret it
i certainly see love between rocky and
and adrian without a doubt but then you
know
athletes have love for each other you
were just talking about all the
all the uh events and sports in this
last week
football players appreciate and love
their opponents
uh even if it's called hate there's a
love there because you have somebody to
test yourself with
the dodgers certainly certainly love
what happened
last night uh with the jays and uh i
mean with the rays and so uh
you know there's love there love that
the guys on the other side
were the ones who suddenly and somehow
lost the game
so i think there's always love with
athletes man and and
maybe they're some of the most loving
people on the planet because they know
what it takes to be where they are
carl weather's here on the rich eisen
show um acting as well as directing
episodes of the mandalorian on disney
plus season two is available
coming up on this friday and we'll get
to that in a second when was the first
time you met al davis
when was that when was that oh whoa in
the wayback machine did you meet him
when
when uh when when you were i imagine uh
two years with the raiders
of course of course no he i mean let's
face it
uh mr davis was literally
there all the time you could not
be a raider and not have met mr davis
[Music]
he was a phenomenal phenomenal
owner a phenomenal football
talent a leader of course of that team
and that franchise
and uh i just remember i i remember him
as very generous because
i was a free agent and of course as a
free agent uh
there wasn't a heck of a lot of money
there you know but
uh i got a small check for for signing
with the raiders
but after i made the team uh
not a lot of people know this uh we were
in training camp
and mr davis came was in
in the the restaurant there we were at
that time we were in santa rosa
california uh at the el rancho motel
which we took over
and uh mr davis was in the the
restaurant and i went up to him because
i received a check
for i think a thousand dollars of
fifteen hundred dollars and i went up to
him and i said
mr davis thank you so much for that
check and he just looked at me
almost astounded me said you earned it
and that was the end of that
oh and your head coach was john madden
did he do
do you have any recollection of a good
conversation you had with him i uh uh
you know when you first arrived or when
maybe you
you got sent uh away from the raiders
well of course i remember it all
john d john madden yes was a heck of a
coach
and of course at that time was
considered a really young man
and um daily on the field
uh one way or another you'd interact
with john and uh
i was reprimanded a number of times for
uh
for uh penalties that were caused as a
result of my
exuberance and uh finally
finally when it was time to um you know
make some decisions
in the second year uh you get that call
and that call is uh you know
uh carl coach wants to see in his office
bring your playbook
at that time we didn't have ipads and
all that sort of gear you know so
you know that uh when it's bring your
playbook
their writings on the wall but i went in
and uh you know he was actually a very
very kind guy
the only part of the whole conversation
that i think to this day still stings is
he said
basically he said to me you know you're
just too sensitive
and i went what i'm a football player
how the hell can i be sensitive
but on the other hand i think he knew
something about me that maybe i didn't
realize at the time
football wasn't really the calling it
was something i was able to do because i
was physical and
and had some athleticism that was
god-given but
you know being in front of the camera
being on the stage that was the calling
carl weather's here on the rich eisen
show
let's talk about the mandalorian here on
disney plus i mean
talk about um a remarkable
career arc for you carl to be part of
the rocky
series and then now being part of star
wars i mean
if you want to talk about i mean star
wars and rocky came out in the same year
back in 1976 and now you are part
uh on disney plus of a remarkable
extension of the star wars genre and
you're directing some of these episodes
as well if i told you back in the day
when you were apollo creed oh by the way
this
this this is going to be a remarkable
film
um arc and i can't even call it a
trilogy um
and now as well as star wars what would
you said
you got to be kidding me as well i bet
right um
you know not a million years quite
honestly had i
thought about it or imagined it or
anything else
my dream has always been to just be in
good projects and with good people and
and excellent writing and to do my best
to be
to be a standout in that and this
opportunity came along and
as a result of of knowing uh john
favreau through the director's guild and
john's saying to me i've got this you
know this project i'm doing and i really
want you to be a part of it and
at first it was really all about acting
and and when we talked and i
really realized what a great role it was
and what a great project i thought it
was going to be
i i said to him you know uh or through
my agents anyway
uh i you know what i really want to do
is direct and i had been directing so it
wasn't anything new but
if we have a second season i'd like to
direct
and john said okay we'll see if we can
work that out and true to his word
it came about so in the second season
carl weathers is also a director
that's fantastic i can i can only
imagine um
it's uh quite a challenge um with
uh how it looks i mean it just pops off
the screen
carl i mean is it is it anything have
you directed anything remotely close to
an episode of the mandalorian well no no
rich
it's it's such a magnificently
orchestrated uh group of artists and and
craftsmen who put this show together
and of course uh the the uh uh
the stage was set really you know with
star wars i mean when you look at those
movies and you see how how
much uh how well put together they are
um and you look at the the amount that
goes on
in a frame in in front of you on the
screen
and the stories as they're told in the
number of characters
um how you know how could you imagine
that
we could as a as a group as a company
through with you know with john favreau
and dave filoni really leading
uh with the great writing that's done
how could we have imagined that we could
even come close to doing that on the
small screen
and of course you've got lucasfilm and
disney and
they're not slouches so you're going to
have you know you're going to have a
great show and
we're very proud of the mandalorian and
people who seem to be
embracing it all over the world well
it's a good thing carl that at least
it's not a fan base that doesn't have
any attention to detail and doesn't get
totally outraged if it's not something
that they think passes the smell test at
least you got that going for your car
absolutely
absolutely and and again i think uh you
know
john favreau has done an amazing job of
marshalling this thing through and
and uh all the computer graphics people
are just brilliant
they're absolutely brilliant so what you
get and what you see
is something that looks like you've you
know you're in that
that outer universe so a couple more
minutes left with you carl um i i i want
to go all over the map with you because
i i can the best running back the best
running back that you ever tackled
in your day college whether it's at san
diego state when you were the fred dryer
or with the raiders
who's give
uh i mean i i don't remember ever ever
hitting anybody and really literally
bouncing off of him
was uh zonka larry zonka with uh the
dolphins
uh i mean the man was massive
and had you know thighs like tree trunks
uh so that to me was one of the toughest
ever
okay and then um we there's a movie that
might not get brought up to you quite a
bit carl at all but you were
uh in close encounters of the third kind
yeah uh what was it like
on the set of that movie with somebody
that was phenomenal i mean i was a young
young actor and it was only uh gosh
it was only maybe a couple months after
rocky
or maybe three months four months after
rocky and uh
my agent got a call and they wanted me
to do that and of course
steven spielberg and what do you say yes
and uh has the british say yes please
and uh i got the sides really i only had
my side of the conversation or the
script
and never read a full script flew down
uh went to wardrobe makeup
went to the set uh met some of the
actors who were
involved in it as well as you know
truffaut was involved
uh of course steven spielberg uh rick
dreifus
we rehearsed the scene we did the scene
i went got a bite to eat was back on a
plane and home within 24 hours
so they didn't give you the full script
it was that top secret they they
didn't want to know no right many many
companies do that these days but
back then i mean it was i i'd never
experienced it before but again you know
the great steven spielberg and and that
company
and and the wonderful movie that turned
out uh as a result of it well it
prepared you for happy gilmore right
that was the same way for happy gilmore
right you didn't get the full scripture
from samurai but a little different it
was sort of the opposite end of the
spectrum with
adam and uh right you know so many
wonderful
actors in that uh that was a lark and it
was one of the
one of the most fun times i've ever had
making a movie because it was
just uh you know a bunch of comedians
and comedic actors and there i was
trying to keep up with them
well i mean you you know at least in
close encounters and you had use of both
hands
um very true would you base the
character of chubs
was very good with one hand yeah of
course you can handle a club just as
well as uh
any guy who had two hands versatile just
like you uh who did you base the role of
chubs on
uh you know i didn't i just dug down
and as i said really tried to keep up
with all those great comedic actors
and uh always loved a good laugh you
know when somebody was
funny yeah and uh just did my best to
you know to to be funny without trying
to be funny well
i mean you must get that from tom does
it surprise you when people come up and
give you chubs whenever you um
no not at all are you kidding me chubbs
is in the cannon man
there are so many people and
particularly particularly those college
age people
who just love chubbs peterson and of
course now you know
these days with television being as
prolific with
reruns as it is and you have so many
more stations
you know you see everything you've done
at one time or another and sometimes
it's there on the loop it's like all day
every day
carl really appreciate the time a lot of
fun uh just going down memory lane with
you
um and congrats on getting the the
second season
and the directing gig gig that you said
hey you'd be interested in and what uh
what a show
what a show the mandalorians it's such a
great uh pleasure to
visit with you again and uh we'll see
you down the road you got it right back
at you that's carl weathers
uh disney plus the new season starts
streaming this friday
right here on the rich eisen show